[Music]
hello and welcome to another edition of
i'd like to know i'm c.a murray and i am
by myself today pastor bohr is preparing
to leave town
to do ministry and has several things to
do this afternoon so um he has left me
here all by myself but i am not
bereft because i'm in the company of the
holy spirit and you are here and we are
glad to be with you
this is i'd like to know this is our
question and answer bible program where
we we have a good time in the lord and i
i say we but today we is me
uh
i'd like to give you an idea of how you
can join in we've gotten an impressive
list of questions i was looking at the
list
that was on uh pastor boris death just
the other day
we've got several questions we've got
many many questions but we can always
take more
we can always accept more so if you will
contact us tv
at some tv.org that is tv at some tv
dot o r g
send in your questions and we will try
to get to them as best we can and we
promise you to answer them from the word
of god the word of god only you don't
need to hear man's opinion in these last
days you need to hear a word from the
lord and that is what we promised to
give you if he will send in your
questions we will try to answer them if
an answer can be found in the word of
god we will find it and we'll bring
it to you we're going to go into prayer
because we've got a couple questions
that may chew up a little bit of our
time today
we'll see how far we can get and how
much we can indeed cover so let's go to
the lord in prayer before we go into his
word
father god again we praise you
we thank you for being a gracious god
we thank you that there is truth in your
word
we are thankful that there is power in
your word there are answers in your word
to direct our lives
and that you choose to speak to us
through your word
would you please speak to us now so that
we hear your voice and understand your
will for our lives and we thank you in
advance
for your promise to hear
and answer the prayer of faith in jesus
name
amen
amen and amen our first question comes
to us
from
um
oh this name o ghetto i guess it is o
ghetto
and o g-e-t-o
and we don't have
a place where this is coming from but
it's a question about the proper
attitude for both public and private
prayer
he says according
to book
of chapter 19 but it does not say what
book
both public and private prayer should be
offered
kneeling down
but on
every ceremony where we see christians
offer prayer standing erect or sitting
down in a chair which i'm doing just now
what can we suggest about this
i looked into the word of god and um
i'm not familiar with the book of prayer
but i did not find any
particular
statements that be speak our body
position when we are praying
the bible tends more to focus on and
concern itself with
your attitude
when you are praying as opposed to
your body position
we have seen prayers in the bible on the
cross
we've seen people praying
uh from the belly of a whale we seen
people praying in times of exigency when
they didn't have time to formally kneel
down in prayer
i think that
it is much more important that our
attitude be right with god
than
our the position of our body let me
refer you to matthew chapter 6.
in matthew chapter 6 i'm going to do a
little reading then i'm going to refer
you to some other verses
without reading them but matthew chapter
6 look let's look at verse 5.
matthew 6 5 and i'm going to read down
through 15
and when you pray you shall not be like
the hypocrites for they love to pray
standing in the synagogues and on the
corners of the streets that they may be
seen of men so their standing is not a
suggestion of position in fact christ is
saying
they do this because they want to be
seen and they want to
sort of show off before men
assuredly i say to you they have the
reward but you when you pray go into
your room and shut and when you have
shut your door
pray to your father who is
in the secret place and your father who
sees in secret will reward you openly
now again no body position is
inferred he's saying go to a private
place
not a public place
and then pour your heart out to your
father and though you are in private
god will reward you openly
and when you pray do not use vain
repetitions as the heathens do for they
think that they will be heard for their
many words
um then of course he he walks the
disciples through
uh what we often call the lord's prayer
now i used this particular text
because christ is speaking here
and we see the words of of the lord in
this manner therefore pray our father
which art in heaven now he's given them
the words but he does not
suggest
a particular position
um
if you forgive men their trespasses your
heavenly father will forgive you so he's
really talking about the attitude that
you ought to come to the lord
uh
before you pray you need to have a
certain mindset
a certain surrendered mindset uh before
you play so i pray before i i don't
think you really get
points i'll use that or credit with the
lord
because you kneel that that would be
legalism that would be trying to i'll
use the term score points with the lord
because you are you are kneeling uh i
don't think god is concerned about the
kneeling or the standing as much as he
is concerned about
the surrendered heart
and the the consecrated soul that comes
to the lord the bible says in jail the
fervent effectual prayer
of a righteous person avails much
so again fervent effectual we want to
come to the lord with a certain mindset
that trusts god that has faith in god
that gives assurance that your prayer is
being heard and your prayer
will be answered
the prayer of faith will save the six
james chapter five
and verse 15.
first corinthians chapter seven
verse five i'm going through this kind
of slow so you can write these down if
you need to
talks about fasting and prayer
paul in his letter to timothy first
timothy chapter 4
and verse 5
talks about the word and prayer
in first peter chapter 3 verse 7
a list of instructions are given to
husbands concerning their wives as joint
heirs
and it says
treat your wife a certain way
a certain respectful way a certain
deferential way so that your prayers are
not hindered so we see that prayer can
be hindered by the way we treat our our
spouse our partner so all of these
suggest a mindset that needs to precede
prayer that needs to accompany our
prayer that we should be in before
during and after we pray
those things are compelling to god as
opposed to a position now
kneeling before the lord shows reverence
it shows deference it shows awe and
respect so it is a good thing to do but
i don't think we should get ourselves
into the position of thinking
that unless we are kneeling our prayers
are not heard
kneeling i think is the best thing to do
because
it shows respect to the god that we are
addressing but it is is it the only way
that we can address god i think not and
i don't see any
prohibition in the bible
that would forbid us to pray unless we
are kneeling and that kneeling is the
only way to come to the lord
it is a wonderful way it is a submitted
way it is a committed way it is a way
that sows our love for and respect for
god but i don't believe it's the only
way and the truth be told there are some
times when you cannot kneel
when things are going on or things are
happening and you cannot kneel and i
believe your sincerity gets through when
uh kneeling cannot i remember uh being
in a car driven by a
a friend of mine and we were getting
ready to slide into some trees
on a
ice slick road
and
he ordered a quick prayer it was it was
it was really fast and um the lord
blessed them and in fact i can remember
driving myself leaving uh irma's house
when we were dating on a cold winter
night and the car did a flip around and
i didn't have time to get formal i just
yelled out to the lord and the lord the
lord saved me the car
slid off the road but it landed right
between two big trees just as though
someone had put it right between two big
trees didn't hit anything didn't uh
break up anything didn't shake up
anything
of course when i called the tow truck
they charged me 75 so
that was quite a bit of money i should
have prayed about that too before i made
that call but nothing happened and and i
didn't have time to kneel i had to call
on the lord right away so
again i think it's your fervency your
faith in god that
is of import to him not necessarily your
kneeling and i hope that
sort of answers that question because
there are sometimes when you just cannot
kneel i think when you can you should
but if you cannot your prayers are still
heard and answered in heaven
all righty
this
particular question uh is going to take
a little time i'm looking at my time
because it's going to take just about
all that we have um
the question asked
what is the biblical validation
of the sj church
for accepting and having
regional conferences and i'll explain
what that is
in some of its union conferences as
these are entirely based on racial
segregation and that is true
regional conferences are conferences
that are particularly made up for and
were
brought into existence in the first one
was 1945.
um they were brought into existence
to
reach out to and to service and to
project their ministry to people of
color to to african americans
they did not exclude uh caucasians or
other ethnic identities and all of the
church i've i've pastored uh i've had
blacks and i've had whites and i've had
other races but regional conferences
came into existence
with the intention of servicing reaching
out to to african americans
one of the answers i would give you
before i go into some research that i've
done over the years on this subject
is
uh
a statement that christ made
about the hardness of
your hearts he was speaking jesus was
speaking in matthew chapter 19
uh matthew 19.
and he said that moses allowed you to
get divorces
because of the hardness of of your
hearts in other words
things existed
in christ's time
and they were not god's original
intention
in a perfect world
they would not
uh re reflect on or be part of
the will of god
but they exist because of the hardness
of certain hearts
and god's desire to do the best he could
in a world
where
people
had hard
hearts
so let's look at let's see
matthew 19 and that's verse
moses because of the hardness of your
hearts permitted you to divorce but in
the beginning it was not so now i've got
a book i've read many many times
you can see the page of the little dog
here a little falling apart because it
bespeaks uh some of these things i want
to give you some quotes some from ellen
white some from this book
and uh they kind of give you uh a
lay of the land when regional
conferences started in the mid
1940s i believe
here's a statement from ellen white
we need not expect that all will be
accomplished in the south that god would
do until
in our missionary efforts we place this
question
on the ground of people and let those
who accept the truth
be educated to be christians
ellen white says you have no license
from god to exclude the colored people
from your places of worship
they should hold membership in the
church with the white brethren so
the
original intent of the lord was for
everybody to worship together
let me go on just a little further in
regard to white and colored people
worshiping together in the same building
this cannot be followed
as a general custom with profit to
either party especially in the south
this is the hardness of your heart
the best thing
would be
to provide the colored people who accept
the truth with places of worship of
their own
in which they can carry on their
services by themselves
this is particularly necessary in the
south in order that the work for white
people may be carried on without serious
hindrance
so
we see in the first reading what god's
will is
we have no license from god to exclude
colored people
but the hardness of your hearts makes
this second reading necessary
uh because of the world
that we found ourselves in now sadly the
the truth is that the history of the
adventist church
to a great degree follows the history of
the
united states of america
i had a professor
c.e mosley great man of god who got to
the general conference and he told me on
many occasions that in the general
conference in the 1940s when he served
that blacks could not eat in the general
conference cafeteria they were excluded
from the general conference cafeteria
there was a call
for the joining of the races in church
going back
to
the the reconstruction era the
post-civil war area but era rather but
the the church was
reticent
uh
not willing because of the hardness of
of their hearts uh to accept that and of
course um
that's why uh james edson
put his school for blacks on a boat so
that when the things got too hot he
could lift anchor and sail out of that
town rather than putting it in a
building that could be burned down or
destroyed many times they were so he was
aware of the the antipathy between
blacks and whites and and the the
negative feelings
that were existence in existence
um during that time
um let me see just a couple of the
things i want to touch on
this is from volume 9 of the testimonies
page 206 207
while washington was giving a speech in
atlanta
ellen white was putting together
material for volume nine of the
testimonies for the church her word
suggests
a plaintive cry for god's special
guidance through that trying period
let the color colored believers be
provided
with neat tasteful houses of worship
let them be shown that this is done
not to exclude them from worshiping with
white people because they are black but
in order that the progress
of the faith be not advanced
let them understand that this plan is to
be followed until the lord shows us a
better way so
in reading her writings
i don't believe that this was supposed
to always be the plan of god
uh blacks wanted to
worship with whites they wanted the
church to be won
but they realized that the church was
not ready for that now i want to run
through something very very quickly i
hope my time allows me to do so
before my time gets away from me i want
to
talk to you about the
incident
and i have spoken with individuals who
were there for this incident and this
was the sort of straw that broke the
camel's back after this thing that i'm
going to read to you happened
blacks
really ceased
desiring and pushing for and angling for
worship with with their white brethren
and they said let us just start
churches of our own conferences of our
own administrative units of our own
uh because it's just it's not going to
work
this concerns lucy barr now this is a
a truth that
most blacks have known about i found out
about this very early on even before i
got into ministry um
here's the story
against the national backdrop of
discrimination this book is uh called we
have tomorrow written by louis b
reynolds i've had it for years i don't
think it's even in print anymore
but
we're talking about a racial incident
occurred at an adventist hospital in
tacoma park maryland
lucy buyered
a gravely ill black woman and long time
adventist from brooklyn new york was
brought to the washington sanitarium
that's currently called the washington
adventist hospital
for treatment
fair-skinned at first she was admitted
very very light-skinned woman
but later when uh admittance forms were
scrutinized and her racial identity was
discovered
she was told a mistake had been made
without examination or treatment she was
wheeled out into the corridor and
transferred across the state line
to virginia
in to friedman's hospital
where she later died of pneumonia
this incident along with another similar
case where no death was involved but the
person was refused treatment stirred the
black constituency in washington to
demand that the general conference act
to ensure that such discriminate
discriminatory and inhumane treatment of
blacks would not
happen again
not only were black members concerned
about admitted to hospitals but the
whole question of quotas to schools
there were some issues with tacoma
academy and quotas uh the lack of
employment in the church
general
uh institutional absence
of solicitude for them in the church
were subjects of their protest press and
pulpit played decisive roles whipping
the sentiment into a fervor and so this
happened in
the first of the regional conferences
began in
1945 and i believe that was the
northeastern conference
so
because of the hardness of hearts
because of the treatment that was
given to black seventh-day adventists
they said let us just work for ourself
now let's look at the results and then
i'll give you
the upshot of this whole argument
although it took nearly 30 years to
accumulate 3 000 black members
it took less than four years
after the reorganization that is after
regional conferences were started to
show an increase of more than 3 500
additional members so what took 30 years
before black or regional conferences
uh happened in just four years once they
were
formed
from 1944
to 1982 approximately 125 000 black
american converts entered the
seventh-day adventist church by baptism
or profession of faith now there's a
long reading from the adventist
encyclopedia
that i'm looking at the clock i will not
have time to go into
but suffice it to say
god took something that was not the best
and
uh used it for good again i believe
because of the hardness of the hearts of
the brethren
which is why ellen white was
forced to or encouraged to by the lord
to write volume 9 of the testimony which
included
much counsel on our duty to what was
then called the colored people
charles m kinney one of the first black
ordained seventh-day adventists he was
ordained by
the
leader of the southern work robert m
kilgore
in 1889 um the
white constituency of that conference
pretty much boycotted that that camp
meeting where he was ordained so that
was the mindset
of the church
in those days and after a while
black said we're not going to knock our
heads against the wall
we'll have to just work for ourselves
because the larger contingency does not
accept us does not want us will not
worship with us so let's just do what we
can they believed in the church they
believed in the message they believed in
the three angels messages they believed
in the sabbath they believed in the
rightness if i can use that term other
seventh-day adventist church it has
never been the seventh-day adventist
church that has been wrong it's been
seventh-day adventists whose hearts were
not right and whose hard hearts forced
this accommodation now the truth be told
is it necessary at this point in time
probably not
and i say probably uh if we were to get
together i think we could live together
we could love together we certainly
could worship together
but the question is whose administrative
structure is going to be torn down and
dissolved into the other should the
black conferences sell their conferences
and their offices and come to the white
conferences or should the white
conferences sell their offices sell
their structure and come to the black
conferences it is more at this point an
economic reality
there certainly are enough black pastors
to reach out and minister to black
people without necessarily having the
black superstructure that is the
conference
above them to administer the work but
it's up and running
and the church has some issues with its
governance and how it addresses itself
they will probably be here till jesus
comes so god has used this imperfect
system to promote a perfect work and to
do that perfect work among his people
you won't find biblical validation for
that what you'll find is a practical
reality if i can't get it done this way
i will as god leads my
efforts i will get it done this way so
it was more a pragmatic reality of the
times in which the church found itself
and the hardness of the hearts of those
in leadership in the church
and
responding to that and not letting the
intransigence
of the racial climate in which the
church found itself and which to a large
extent it was part of
that forced blacks to do what they
needed to do if they wanted to reach
their people
and they're still doing a wonderful job
i served in a regional conference in new
york city all of my 30 years of ministry
18 years pastoring
and um uh
12 plus years in the conference office
at sabbath school communications public
affairs religious liberty director and
the lord was was blessing uh had several
evangelistic crusades went around the
world
serving for the lord that was the
reality of the situation we
had meetings with
our caucasian brothers brethren and got
along with them very very well because
that's what christians should do um
that's what christians ought to do what
they are called to do but
there is a a history a history of the
united states
and sadly a history in the seventh-day
adventist church we have not always been
what we should have been but we've
always been the people of god even with
our imperfections
and so we rise above our imperfections
and we strive to do the work of the lord
as best we can
as god gives us strength and god calls
us to be pure and holy in our actions
and our dealings one with another this
book is a great book
we have tomorrow it has some material on
the civil war that uh really is is
mind-blowing as to the demonic insertion
into
the ranks of the southern armies and the
ranks of the northern armies uh satan
worked quite
hard to try to destroy this country and
dull its effect uh for sharing the
gospel but um we have tomorrow lewis b
reynolds if you can get find a copy uh
you need to get one ooh our time is fine
fast flipping into eternity see you
again next time god bless keep studying
your word
[Music]
you